bonsoir dans barry merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on l'a vu
en les réactions indignées inégalités
traitement caractère sexiste
pensez vous qu'il s'agissait d'un choix
délibéré de la turquie de reléguer or
sud à van der leyen sur le canapé alors
à la décharge de monsieur erdogan il
semblerait que le protocole était avait
été validé par les la diplomatie
européenne
donc c'est pas que ce soit un instant
mais mais auront dans le genre peut-être
un peu plus dans les jours qui viennent
après est-ce que erdogan en a profité
sûrement il faut il ne faut pas oublier
que c'est un record
un homme politique avisé aux usa et par
opportunisme et la culture d'en profiter
de cette situation pour pouvoir
humiliés encore une fois comme il le
fait habituellement à l'europe
déstabilisé aussi ses interlocuteurs qui
était sur le point de négocier avec lui
déstabilisation psychologique mais aussi
séoul où ce qui pour lui un message
envoyé à sa base électorale a ses
partisans mais au delà dans le monde
arabo musulman
on le sait dans les mouvances islamistes
de l'islam politique
erdogan est considéré comme un modèle
bois comme le nouveau khalife donc c'est
une réussite de ce point de plus les
titres diplomatique
ça veut dire que dans le monde arabo
musulman comment vous gouttes
il ya une forme de caution c'est ce
qu'on vous êtes en train de vous dire
franchement c'est pas si mal de reléguer
un canapé attention je n'ai pas dit ça
je vous pose la question
non je précise surtout dans la mouvance
et tout ce qui des soutiens erdogan ou
d'aidé ou des supplétifs notamment les
fruits la turquie est en tout cas elle
rejette la faute sur le protocole
européen vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne manière de se défendre pour ankara
ils sont dans leur rôle les turcs sont
mon rôle est donc c'est vrai que sur le
fond on en cours est ce qu'on pourrait
se poser beaucoup de questions sur
l'attitude de européenne sur donc déjà
premièrement première erreur je me
demande pourquoi ce sont les
représentants européens qui rende visite
à quelqu'un qui les insultent qui les
provoque
et lorsqu'on connaît le rôle d'erdogan
dans la région d'arlit à la méditerranée
orientale aussi avec ses précédentes
provocation envers la france à la grèce
et chypre
c'est quand même étonnant que ce soit
les européennes qui se déplace ensuite
et la raison de rejeter cette polémique
sur l'attitude européenne puisque on
peut aussi se demander pourquoi monsieur
michel et madame von der leyen ont réagi
de la sorte avec avec autant de
passivité
s'il a lu un tant soit peu de dignité
serait peut-être manifester ou manifeste
quitter les négociations ou au moins
manifesté leur désapprobation
c'est ce qui est recherché selon vous
j'étais hyper drôle parce qu'il a quand
même manifester des signes d'apaisement
provoqué un incident diplomatique ce
n'était peut-être pas la meilleure idée
pour apaiser la situation
non parce qu'il savait qu ils savaient
très bien comme qu'il n'y aurait pas de
l'action je pense c'est un thème
psychologue
tout n'est pas parfaitement cesser ses
interlocuteurs je pense que en les
déstabilisant et d'une manière aussi en
les humiliant
c'était aussi le moyen pour lui même
avec ces mains tendues pour relancer le
débat pour relancer les discussions
c'était un moyen de se mettre en
position de force et de mettre justement
les représentants européens en position
de faiblesse
je savourais convoi d
ces images elle date de 2015 ça se
passait à antalya erdogan qui avait
accueilli à l'époque donald tusk 1 l'ex
présidente du conseil européen donc le
charles michel d'aujourd'hui et jean
claude juncker avec ce président de la
commission européenne lui reçu l'aval
d'haleine aujourd'hui bien comme par
hasard les trois hommes sont voilà assis
côte à côte en toute égalité qu'est ce
qui s'est passé quelle est la différence
aujourd'hui en 2021
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure c'est
ce qui nous fait penser que c'est peut
être là et c'est sûrement pas mon petit
trait quatre foulées de la parodie comme
comme le démontre votre comme le
demandait aux images à l'époque avec les
deux les deux même grade on peut dire
l'hiérarchie qu dans responsabilités
européennes
les deux représentantes qui sont deux
hommes sont assis côte à côte
entourant le président de l'asnl a ici
madame von der leyen une femme et donc
pour ceux qui en douteraient encore
c'est peut-être une manière aussi aux
erdogan de nous révéler son idéologie
les dolomites la misogynie le sexisme de
son idéologie
aujourd'hui qui sort le plus affaibli de
cette séquence parce qu'on a entendu
beaucoup de responsables politiques y
compris en france nous dire voilà
l'europe le paillasson de la turquie
l'europe
humilié est ce que vous vous partagez
ce sentiment oui je pense parce que
c'est un camouflet pour l'europe
aujourd'hui encore la polémique la
polémique hier oui vous avez un petit
peu perdues c'est pour ça non je disais
que je disais que oui là je pense que
c'est un camouflet que l'europe
malheureusement encore une fois surtout
devant devant erdogan s'est tu ça prouve
au delà de au delà de la gestion a été
plutôt chaotique de la pandémie et de
l'âge et de ses conséquences
ça prouve encore une fois comme la
fameuse phrase je le rappelle que
l'europe est un n géopolitique et
qu'elle n'est pas encore quel nom
qu'elle possède encore beaucoup de
divisions de son enseigne qu'elle n'a
pas de politique étrangère car ça peut
être de nature à remettre en cause ses
volonté d'apaisement
visiblement resté pas parce qu'il ya
quand même eu cette rencontre non je
pense que je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
suites politiques visiblement de
parcelles de par ce déplacement en gare
à l'europe montre montre qu'elle montre
qu'à le cherche elle aussi à
l'apaisement et au bois derrière bien
sûr l'allemagne qui elle est la plus
inquiète de de relations dégradées avec
la turquie pour des tas de raisons au
niveau commercial ou pas de sa porte
communauté turque sur son territoire
mais aussi avec la pression qu erdogan
mais avec le des réfugiés et les
migrants
merci roland barthes géopolitologue
spécialiste du moyen-orient d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france